[Música]
boa noite
eu vim aqui pra contar uma história era
uma vez um gigante e era um gigante
muito especial
era um gigante que tinha muitos dons
ele era um gigante que tocava piano
tocava violão tocava flauta tocava
violino que era sua grande paixão e era
um gigante que um dia eu olho pra mim e
perguntou de gelo que se toca
depois de me contar que ele tocava sete
instrumentos eu toco terror é a única
coisa que eu faço bem feito e me sentir
super pequenininha e ver que eu tentei
várias vezes enlouquecedora uma
professora de filme não conseguirá na e
esse gigante tocava sete instrumentos
bom
além disso ele pintava e pintava muito
bem
ele pintava quadros e um desses quadros
acabou indo pro lupi ele conseguiu expor
no fi e o que tem esse gigante a ver com
o que a gente está fazendo hoje
eu acho que é um detalhe na vida desse
gigante esse gigante é um menino de 12
anos que tinha uma doença muito
complicada no pulmão
ele tinha uma brossi pulmonar idiopática
o nome é complicado a doença é mais
ainda
então esse menino se manteve ligado a um
fio a vida inteira ea vida dele estava
sempre por um fio mas isso não impediu
que ele andasse bicicleta que ele
pintasse que ele não foi pelo frio mas a
obra foi que ele tivesse tudo isso e
fosse muito amato
mas ele foi crescendo ea doença foi
piorando e chegou num ponto que ele
precisava de um transplante
precisava de um transplante pulmonar a
equipe se dividiu
faz o transplante ou não faz o
transplante ele não queria
ele era um menino extremamente religioso
e ele achava que se fosse para fazer o
transplante deus ea mandar um sinal
a família também não queria porque já
tinha tido um caso na família de
transplante que não deu certo a família
não queria até que ponto como equipe de
saúde a gente pode a gente tem o direito
de dizer não vai fazer e pronto é tua
vida vamos salvar
é claro que a gente tem que pensar muito
mas pensar quem pensar como pensar onde
até quando até onde esse gigante
conseguiu equipe inteira parasse para se
pensar se a gente vai ter que conversar
sobre isso a gente vai ter que se reunir
e tentar chegar a um acordo então se a
gente pensar a gente fez criou que tem o
nome do menino
o comitê de bioética hospitalar então eu
no hospital agora a gente tem esse
comitê
o que é isso quando a gente fala é um
comitê de bioética
a gente vai dar a norma não a gente vai
sentar e conversar sobre o caso
então o que a gente fez a gente junto a
várias pessoas com vários cabides cada
um com o seu saber cada um com uma peça
de um quebra cabeça como se fosse um
quebra e eu sou psicóloga eu tenho a
minha pecinha eu consigo ver esse menino
pelo lado psi mas isso é tudo não é
eu não consigo ter uma visão ampla do
caso dele então o que nós fizemos nós
juntamos vários saberes no comitê de
bioética tem médico tem um enfermeiro
tem assistente social tem teólogo tem
filósofo e psicólogo nutricionista e
mais vários saber que cada um com a sua
peça do quebra-cabeça cada um para
mostrar como é que a gente vai discutir
sobre isso cada um e e assim gente e
sempre pensando na criança e na família
todas as reuniões são comunicados à
família e muitas delas não todas a
família
a participar e muitas vezes a criança
participa
então a gente vai pensar nos confiou nos
conceitos básicos da bioética não vou
dar uma lição de bioética aqui pra vocês
que não é não é o caso mas os conceitos
básicos
a gente vai pensar sempre na autonomia
do paciente
o menor que ele seja ele tem que ter
autonomia à doença no corpo dele e
autonomia é deixar com que ele se torne
um agente no processo de doença e o
comitê vai fazer com que a gente dê vida
em processo de morte
isso que é o importante então a gente
vai pensar sempre o que é importante pra
ele o que ele pode fazer
ele quer não quer ficar na cama ele que
não vamos discutir pensar nisso até que
ponto vai a autonomia dele até que ponto
uma criança de 12 anos pode dizer não
quero transplante
sabendo que não transplantar ele vai
morrer
então como é que fica isso
o comitê tem poder para dizer então não
traz planta não mas a gente tem que
pensar sobre isso dá voz àquela criança
é aquela família
depois a gente pensa na b deficiência
a beneficência o conceito que não pode
ser esquecida em momento algum
às vezes a gente não consegue sará como
no caso dele não dava mais pra assar a
não tinha cura mas aí entra o cuidar e
esse cuidado tem que ser muito ampliados
passando da beneficiência já vai pensar
na não uma eficiência
se a gente não pode fazer o bem o mal a
gente melhor aí então o que a gente pode
fazer para que não cause mal a gente a
gente vive numa sociedade onde a gente
pensar a gente mantém uma pessoa viva
muitos anos mas o que é vida o que evita
ficar nu em uma uti entubados em contato
com o mundo
isso evita então é parar e pensar e uma
coisa que o comitê trás que é muito
forte é assim o que é vida não pra mim
angela
eu tenho meu conceito de vida e não
interessa interessa o que é vida para
aquele paciente para aquela família o
que é importante para aquele paciente
para aquela família não pra mim eu tô lá
pra pensar junto com os outros e
conseguiram ampliar essa visão e ver
esse paciente essa família de um jeito
muito maior muito mais amplo
a gente vai pensar também no conceito de
justiça o que é justo o que ele tem
direito o que pode o que não pode é a
gente pode dizer não faz o transplante
legalmente eu posso dizer isso então tem
advogado no concelho no comitê
tudo vai ser discutido todos os pró seco
são ser pesadas
esses quadros que vocês estão vendo são
todos dele tá ele pintou todos esses
quatro
a gente tem que passar também a bioética
é príncipe a lista não cobre todas essas
questões
as questões são muito mais amplas a
gente cata está pensando na vida humana
na vida de uma criança numa vida que vai
impactar não só a vida dela mas a vida
da família e eu não contei no comecinho
ele era um menino tão com tanta vontade
de aprender e de passar que ele criou
uma escolinha ele tinha uma escola onde
ele ensinava as outras crianças a a
pintar é eu tenho com autorização da
família algumas fotos se vocês vão ver
vocês podem até ter visto ele na mídias
porque ele apareceu muito então o qq
vida para o menino que adorava andar de
bicicleta mesmo ligado por um fio que
adorava pintar que adorava escrever
poesia que adorava se comunicar que
gostava de festa que a vida fica numa
uti
no respirador então tudo isso é
discutido nesse comitê pede a gente não
tá lá pra dá ordem para médico não é
essa questão a gente nunca lá pra julgar
gente tá lá pra ajudar para dividir uma
missão não deve ser fácil você atender
uma criança desde os dois anos de idade
chega uma hora que não tem mais o que
fazer
vai pra casa morrer então nessa hora o
cuidado tem que ser muito maior ea gente
tem que pensar na ética das virtudes
o primeiro ponto é a compaixão não é
aquela com paixão clichê é a compaixão
de sentir a vulnerabilidade do outro e
perceber como o outro é vulnerável e
respeitar e cuidar a acolher essa
vulnerabilidade competência profissional
qualquer profissional da área de saúde e
isso eu acredito que em qualquer área
precisa ter competência profissional
você precisa saber e tem de meios
técnicos da melhor forma para lidar com
aquela pessoa esse acolhimento é
importante isso é respeito ao paciente
isso é respeito às famílias
isso é respeito ao trabalho que a gente
chorou seguir confidencialidade
eu tenho que respeitar a vida dessa
criança ou dessa adulto dessa família o
que eles me dizem é sagrado e eu tenho
que acolher enquanto que a gente discute
em equipe mas a gente tem que ter
cuidado porque tem coisas que não podem
ser discutidas e não é gente porque
existe uma lei que não me deixa falar
que se eu falar eu posso ser processada
isso não interessa
a questão tem que ser interna então é
nesse sentido nem colhimento que a gente
tem que pensar a gente só consegue
cuidar e curar
quando o outro com firma gente se não
existe essa confiança eu não vou
conseguir criar pontes né
para para chegar no
e ele precisa confiar em mim e eu
preciso confiar nele eu preciso confiar
na equipe que está atendendo eu não fui
psicóloga desse desse menino ele foi
super bem acompanhado não foi comigo mas
por ser do comitê e eu atendi esse caso
não preciso confiar no trabalho com a
psicóloga está fazendo e assim por
diante
se a gente não confiar se a gente não
tiver uma transparência nesse
atendimento não vai com a coisa não vai
andar consciência eu preciso parar e
refletir o que eu estou fazendo o que eu
estou fazendo está indo de acordo com
esses parâmetros o que eu posso fazer
mais e parar e refletir parar e ouvir
ouvir aquela família houve a equipe que
tá todo mundo sofrendo nessa hora
então ea consciência nesse sentido
gente esse é o menino então se vocês
forem ver e evitar com oxigênio tempo
inteiro ele está ligado por um fio essa
questão ele trouxe pra gente o hospital
que agora está fazendo 100 anos
esse menino trouxe uma lição que não
teve preço
ele trouxe a lição que sozinho não sou
ninguém que eu preciso sentar e discutir
com os outros eu preciso acolher o saber
dos outros eu preciso respeitar o saber
da moça que está fazendo a faxina ela tá
lá o tempo inteiro ela sabe às vezes
muito mais do que eu que entro falo e
vai embora
ela está acompanhando então ela tem que
falar também
às vezes a pessoa que está fora que é da
comunidade chega numa reunião e tem uma
sacada incrível que a gente que já está
com aquele olhar tão viciado não tem
então essas pontes e esse respeito pelo
saber do outro é muito importante uma
pecinha só eu faço um quebra cabeça
a gente vai precisar de vários saberes
para conseguir montar e é isso que é
importante
menino nos trouxe uma uma vivência que
foi única
e que a gente espera e graças a deus
está conseguindo repetir em muitos casos
ea gente o que é que essa forma de
resolver conflito seja só entrará muros
a gente quer que isso passe que isso
seja uma filosofia de vida
a filosofia de olhar para o outro como
alteridade de respeitar o outro como um
ser plena igualzinho a mim que tem a
vontade dele não a minha e eu não tenho
direito nenhum tempo de banho de
cachoeira e conseguiu é tomar
então gente gente tem muito a agradecer
esse gigante porque pelos ombros dele
nós conseguimos enxergar muito muito
além
[Aplausos]